let's go to uh oh i want to go to
john from philly amigo dominicano john
from philly how are you today my friend
hey davey how are you sir good how are
you
good good uh i have a question for you
yeah i don't know if this has been
brought to you before
um why i am democrat
why do do democrats sometimes
in politics are so weak like
i don't know like i cannot explain like
a week or paying over or you know i'm
easily been over for
for the republican to do anything they
want
uh it seems to be like this is all
over every time because even when they
are not in power
yeah i mean when they are even in power
like when they take the house the senate
the presidency even republicans can
screw them over for anything like and
they seem to be like
easily i don't know like
i don't know how i can explain no you're
you're explaining it beautifully
i don't have an answer for you i wish i
had so
here's the one thing i would say john
there's something to be
said for not stooping
down to the level of the right like i
understand the concept of
the right to lacks morality
they are total hypocrites they'll do
whatever the hell they'll say one thing
in 2016 in order to prevent
a nominee to get on the court and then
they'll say something different and like
they have no morality whatsoever
and there's something to be said about
not stooping to their level but you're
bringing up a good point which is
at some point don't you need to start
winning
correct like they i mean
it's always the right always screw thing
over all the time
yes even we lodge it
you know the the right sometimes they
never have logic and
they they have they retarted
to to win anything filthy you know yeah
but the problem is you know i do think
that the problem is
if the left uses the right's dirty
tactics to win
aren't we as bad as they are in some
sense
i don't know i don't know the answer to
that yeah me neither
right but i share your concern i share
your concern and what's going on now
with the supreme court is
it's it's disgusting but it's also
totally predictable right
correct correct yeah i agree uh john are
you voting in person by mail what are
you doing
i'm thinking to going to go in person
okay we will see how
things going and will you try to do
early voting or november 3rd you think
i don't know because in pennsylvania i
don't know when they open
to right go and go in person i think
it's soon i think it's very soon
it's very soon okay i think when it's
available i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
also as soon as i
can all right john i appreciate the
phone call
all right david you have a wonderful day
today okay you too take care
bye there's uh john from philly
originally from the dr we love john
let's go
next to our caller from the 347
area code who's calling today from three
four seven
hey david uh my name is michael and
thanks for taking my call
um so i am a committed democrat um
michael i'm sorry to have to interrupt
you you're gonna have to uh you're gonna
have to back away from the phone a
little or drop your voice down to a more
reasonable level because you're
you're i'm about to blow an eardrum oh
no
oh no okay um so i'm a committed
democrat
uh 66 years old native new yorker
and i have one major concern yes so
do you think that the democratic party
is
really really prepared with strategies
to deal with the red mirage right
okay let me explain what that is to
people so so red mirage is the idea that
because biden voters are much more
likely to vote absentee
that you could have states where it's
close where on election night
trump has a small lead and then in the
days that follow
as the absentee ballots are counted joe
biden takes a lead
and the fear is that in the intervening
time
donald trump will use the lawyers we
know he has ready to go
to try to stop the counting of absentee
ballots or do other things
so your question was do i think
democrats are ready to deal with that
the answer is
no i think that they are partially ready
we did
get a report late last week that joe
biden and the democratic party
are getting numerous lawyers ready to
try to deal with this
but the the problem is that you
fundamentally have an advantage if
you're playing offense because you know
what the strategy is if you are playing
defense in this case by definition
you're at a disadvantage
because you're playing defense against
what you believe they are going to try
but they may try things you're not
prepared for so i think that
on a scale of one to ten the left is
probably at a five or six in terms of
being ready to deal with red mirage
okay so if i could go further with my
question
um you know how for example when
democratic candidates are preparing for
debates
yeah and what happened like for example
right now you have pete buddha judge
supposedly is helping
kamala harris and he's playing the role
of mike pence
right and what they're doing is they're
practicing and they're anticipating
like one anticipates chess moves sure
so if that's the approach so i would
like to i would
think that we would be needing to do
that anticipating a variety of different
moves
no doubt that we would have to make
because as you correctly stated we're
not going to know
exactly all the all the things that
trump will do
and yes they because they're on offense
you're absolutely right
but i'm just wondering is there anything
that any of us
could do i'm just an average citizen you
have a prominent position
in in the political world but i'm just
wondering is there anything that would
that can be done to get the message
across
to uh leading the leaders of the
democratic party
that they need to be fully strategizing
in
every single way possible to anticipate
every possible move the republicans may
make
so unfortunately i think on this one
being so close to november
if the democratic party doesn't already
know that they need to be ready for this
i don't know that there's much we
can do i think what we can do is to make
sure that at the individual level people
understand for example
if you are in line to vote before polls
close you can vote
don't be tricked into being told you
can't vote right because this is how
they could turn they could
do effect turnout we need to sort of
inform people at the individual level
because we're only six five and a half
weeks out at this point
if the democratic party's not ready for
red mirage it's over
like there's nothing you or i at this
point can do sadly i hope that they are
ready i don't know if they are
yeah well hey my obviously my concern is
not alleviated but your answer is
absolutely right on the money as usual
thank you david so
anyway thanks for what you do you have a
great show and i just love your clarity
and your analysis
and you your contributions to the
political discussions so valid
so keep doing what you're doing and i
wish you all the you know continued
success
pleasure having you on i really do
appreciate the phone call let's take a
quick break
if you are holding and that's an if um
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones momentarily
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
the link is under this video and you can
save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david